but uh but uh that being said well let's
let's let's move just
outside of just aoc because we got the
story from reuters
u.s congress to hold hearings on
gamestop trading
state of stock markets they say the u.s
house financial services
and senate banking committee said on
thursday they will hold hearings on the
stock market after users of investment
apps
face trading limits following the reddit
rally that put a charge
into gamesup and other volatile stocks
that were touted in online forums
quote we must deal with the hedge funds
whose unethical conduct directly led to
the recent market volatility
and we must examine the market in
general and how it has been manipulated
by hedge funds
and their financial partners to benefit
themselves while others pay the price
said rep maxine waters a democrat who
leads the house panel
my respect to maxine waters for saying
it but let me follow up on that in a
second
waters added that the hearing will focus
on short selling online trading
platforms
gamification and their systemic impact
on our capital markets and retail
investors then go on to explain what
happened with gamestop
quote we're f we're done letting hedge
fund billionaires treat the stock market
like their personal playground
then taking their ball home as soon as
they lose
said rep ro khanna who noted that hedge
funds were allowed to continue trading
stocks
while individual investors were
handicapped by trading limits on
robinhood
aoc and ted cruz were among growing
numbers of lawmakers who agreed
congress needed more information ted
cruz responded to aoc
saying he fully agreed and then we know
what happened after that aoc then comes
out and rags on ted cruz which is dumb
they going to mention u.s rep rashida
talay but democrat called the
restriction beyond absurd
tulabe urged on twitter that congress
quote have a hearing on robin hood's
market manipulation
they're blocking the ability to trade to
protect wall street hedge funds
stealing millions of dollars from their
users to protect people who've used the
stock market as a casino
for decades reach well let me come back
to that maxine waters thing
i got respect for maxine for saying this
i think she's full of it and i think
she's lying to us she's a career crony
democrat who's probably gonna be like we
gotta stop these hedge funds
i don't really mean it and and we're
gonna we're gonna make sure the little
people are protected
i'm just kidding hedge funds keep
donating to me that's what's gonna
happen well a lot of people inside of
congress are accused of insider trading
because of
their insider knowledge that they get
and many people point out that
according to some instances they abused
those privileges and they abused those
powers if we had a just
system janet yellen would recuse herself
right now immediately
because of her ties to citadel and she
should be brought in front of congress
to testify about
why is she not doing anything well she's
the treasury secretary
i don't care if she's a woman that's
what the biden administration keeps
bringing up
i care about her connections her not
actually rectifying this situation
as americans are essentially being
robbed at gunpoint this is essentially
what's happening here
we are seeing armed robbery happening
right now by
the financial institutions by wall
street that are bringing a gun
putting it to the american people's head
and saying give me that money we're
taking it from you no
you can't do anything about it no luke
yeah luke no
okay they're not bringing the gun
someone else is bringing the gun for
them
do you know who that is who is it who
who's the one who comes the gun to
to to enforce the actions of the crony
establishment elites
police the government yeah it's it's
it's these big businesses
that that can restrict your ability to
trade they've rigged the game against
you
and you can do nothing about it nothing
nope no i mean they can no one arrests
them
who oh i'm sorry i'm sorry could could
someone just give me a quick reminder
who got arrested from 2008
in the market crash and i remember
no one didn't they got rewarded
certainly that can't be correct
they got rewarded for their reckless
dangerous behaviors that brought on the
crash and then the federal reserve came
in and they bailed them out
and i remember i'll tell you who got
arrested the occupy wall street
activists
they got arrested who tried to scramble
on wall street symbolically and they
couldn't even do that
peacefully and i remember being on wall
street right after the 2008 scandal
and i and i bought a fake wallet and i
put an invisible fish line on it i left
some dollars in there
and i threw it right at the stock
exchange right and then we have these
big wall street brokers walking around
this is the official video you could
actually watch on my youtube channel we
are change
and then and then you know we had this
big wall street guy trying to pick it up
he bent over tried to pick up the wallet
we yanked it
ran up with the video cameras we had
this huge video camera i'm like
when is enough enough for you sir why
are you stealing from the american
people
and then they were just like oh wait
what are you doing here police came in
that guy
uh probably some wall street broker but
it was random people that i was messing
with the police came
and they're like you have to leave i'm
like no i don't what are you talking
about they're like you're literally
no i'm not i'm holding it with a string
they're like you're loitering i'm like
no i'm walking i could walk around a
little bit too and
they literally threatened to arrest me
about 12 times because i just
i just kept moving down the block but i
kept i kept getting all these wall
street guys
um and that's that's that's the way it
works the people who
are are robbing you when the big banks
got away with all this
the government took your money and gave
it to them yeah
they they played dirty they lost it and
the government said give us all your
money or you go to prison
we have the guns and we're gonna go give
it to these guys when the police
officers came to him i'm like guys what
are you doing the criminals are in there
they're the ones robbing your your your
mortgages your retirements
your pensions they're taking your money
away from you and you're trying to
arrest me guys god come on you guys
go get this guy right here he's trying
to steal my money
and i yanked it it was hilarious i loved
it i had a bunch of fun doing this right
all right
but but we got we got rep jeff duncan he
made a statement as well
he said tonight i am leading a
bipartisan group of lawmakers and
calling for the sec to investigate robin
hood
and other financial institutions for
their unprecedented
and harmful actions against individual
investors wall street shouldn't get to
play by a different set of rules
and then he tags gamestop and wall
street bets
moderator twitter account we'll see if
it actually isn't the sec
the the people that told robin hood to
stop
issuing advice we don't know that didn't
they say because
no in their email it has something the
email was said we have
obligations to the sec in certain
circumstances okay so the the company
the situ the people that they're
obligated to cut off their buys
to is now supposed to investigate them
for cutting off their buys
we don't know if the sec actually did
that but they said they're obligated to
the sec but they didn't say for what
it's a manipulation
but they did something and then they
said we're obligated to the sec to
behave
in this fashion to we're to we're
obligated to provide certain things
so they didn't say the sec actually told
us to do anything it's a trick
it's a way they twist language to make
you assume
it's it's it's a manipulation technique
you'll say something like
hey uh did you ever do do x and then the
person says i don't remember
that way they're not officially lying
you see like there's ways to use tricks
to answer people in ways that doesn't
actually answer the question or makes
them believe things
that are not true well i support any
investigation of these guys i mean what
do they plan on
on uncovering or finding out or
accomplishing with this sec thing
whether or not they broke the law i
suppose and rips people off not that i'm
confident they'll actually do it the
system's been broken and rigged for a
long time yeah the system's messed up
so we have this post on reddit it's
going viral
i don't know if it's true and i gotta
say probably not
true i would actually give it a high
probability of not being true so i want
to make sure i say that
and i and i often you know whenever we
do highlight
rumors and statements online like this
usually it's because a lot of people are
sharing it
there's 1743 comments there's
what do we have 27 24 700 up votes on
this post on reddit
a lot of people are seeing it and i want
to make sure it's clear
not confirmed in any capacity but here's
what they said
this is you this is from user odin 19199
robin hood insider information they said
i work for robin hood don't kill me
low level technical s comp sciences
major not finance side
guess what we overheard today vladimir
yes the founder vladimir
and the c-suite received calls from
sequoia capital and the white house
that pressured into closing trading on
gme i guarantee you this is the same
that took place at e-trade and others
who closed trading
file reports on the sec page if i wasn't
scared to be out of work in a pandemic
i'd quit
i'm disgusted we all need to rise up
this is bad as it gets when we talk
about how the rich get off
get one set of rules and the rest get us
get screwed over and over and over again
and left to bail them out and pick up
the tab for their trillion dollar tax
breaks
we need to pile pressure on every
government and financial institution
involved in this travesty of justice
i am taking a massive career risk even
posting here but fd's mother efforts now
hold on sequoia capital i believe
sequoia right
said it is absolutely not true this is a
rumor it's not true
and i gotta say it's the internet it
probably isn't and i know a lot of you
probably saw it
but to me it looks bogus well it doesn't
look real it
looks absolutely coordinated to have all
these right places doing it at once on
the same morning
yeah it's coordinated definitely these
people all know each other birds of a
feather flock together there's no way
they don't know each other
you look at the people from in silicon
valley they all know each other
they all do in the white house they're
saying the white house is involved with
the
federal reserve chair now as the
treasury sector see trump would have
been on twitter
talking about it biden said nothing he's
he's the
he's the corporate guy that is working
for the numbers
trump was the fire brand and whether or
not we wanted trump out there dividing
and yelling and pointing fingers
or biden back there pulling switches joe
bidens joe
joe biden's uh advisors and and
transition team and all that stuff
they represent this stuff dude the truth
is the fed ex federal reserve chair
come on yeah she's the the the head of
the snake
what we're watching right now is now
that they've taken control of the
executive branch
they can laugh in our faces and just sit
back and put their feet up and say do
something what do you do about it
nothing
your mouth we can rig the system we can
steal from you
and there is nothing you can do to stop
it
they put janet yellen in charge of the
you know
eliza i liked your statement earlier
about keeping it pure because i feel
like we've kind of almost derailed to
politics and we're going and politics is
going to play an important oversight in
this but when you say keeping
the movement pure what do you mean well
i'm going to try to be very gracious in
saying this because i don't want to
jeopardize the channel but i've
i've seen in the past movements that
seemingly have a great message
or a good cause be co-opted by folks
uh maybe that are too aggressive too
passionate or with misinformation
it's happened in the space that i move
in it's happened in other things
you know throughout the summer and then
previously as well this is
a tale as old as time if we keep it
about the little person
and give them a chance to succeed and
don't make it about anything else
just a little person give them a chance
to succeed and give them a voice
then i think that we could see some
change but
um it's it's hard i don't want to say
something weird
no no no need that time to say something
weird but i just i don't want to say
anything with jeopardize the channel so
so i will leave it there what i'm
getting here is so somebody credited
this
and we kind of laughed at this somebody
credited this to trumpism and i was
thinking about it all day today and i
was like how do we know this is not
something like
trumpism because this is normal people
doing normal person things thinking they
can make a difference
no because trumpism is a made-up word
that means nothing it doesn't mean
anything
it's a way to be like there's no trump
anymore but how can we say the word
trump
trumpism they're they're acting like
anti-establishment and populism is only
trump
yeah okay i'm sure the left who's
complaining about this and cheering on
is a bunch of trump supporters yeah
trumpism also we have to understand it's
not out of the stretch of imagination
that the government couldn't be involved
here i mean we already have the
mainstream media we already have big
tech
and we know a lot of the big wall street
banksters even according to some
beijing professors knowingly worked very
well with politicians and were able to
influence them to get to their way so
if if the chinese were able to do it
with wall street and and politicians
what makes you think that you know a lot
of these powerful billionaires aren't
able to pull the strings of government
as well
and helped orchestrate what happened
today which is essentially
preventing people from buying stocks
in companies i mean this is just robin
hood wild and these other platforms are
supposed to exist that most people get a
modest return and cr and a lot of people
get ripped off bad
they want little people to have access
to direct trading so that you can
panic and lose your money and they can
steal it from you
it's not supposed to go the other
direction yeah so uh robin hood
created a one-way valve by getting rid
of buying on these stocks
the stocks can only go one direction
they said hmm
people weren't supposed to realize the
trick people weren't supposed to have
the power to implement this
the hedge funds with billions of dollars
to throw around right
they can control the markets with their
weight
regular investors can't what happens
when five million people get together
and all stand on that scale well then
their weight makes a difference so they
had to shut it down
and they showed us they did it they
showed us straight up they're like hey
guys just want to let you know
we're disabling this function because
you're not allowed to succeed
go to hell but it red pills people and
people never forget
that red pill that red pill stays and
i'm not meaning red pill is in a
political way i mean like
you take the red pill your eyes are open
and then you see what's really going on
so this is gonna red pill a lot of
people and once you've been red pill
it's almost there's no going back
you start seeing it the veil is lifted
from your eyes you know the whole
thing's a wash and so you can act
accordingly right yeah
so i'm excited for that i'm excited that
people are getting the opportunity to
see okay look
this is how it really is the odds are
stacked against us so what are we going
to do
yeah that's tough man what do we do
money into cryptocurrency
i'm not an expert but you're not an
expert it's not advice
and that is not advice you could do if
you want to get out of the america no
it's not something that you could do
it's something
you will do something i have done and
something i will continue to do
whether or not anyone else should or
could not do it as all of their
financial advisors
yes yeah it was intense god's energy
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time